le problème en fait c'est que il ya des
gens qui vont comme ça à l'étranger pour
des facettes bien sûr le problème c'est
qu'ils repartent avec autre chose que
des facettes ils repartent avec des
couronnes et en fait une couronne
nécessite vraiment de beaucoup taille et
la dent et dans le cas où les dents sont
saines c'est de la mutilation d'organes
vivants parce que riz dans ce sont des
organes maintenance et alors lauriano
dentaire cden donné plein de conseils
parce que c'est vrai qu'il ya des trucs
de fou qui se passe
ce
qu'on voit là en fait c'est s'aider
préparation pour des couronnes en fait
pour pouvoir poser une facette c'est une
préparation vraiment pelliculaire c'est
à dire que on enlève quasiment rien là
dedans il ya même des facettes sans
préparation on n'a pas besoin de faire
tout ça fait quand on taille la dent
comme ça c'est pour accueillir une
couronne palace a cédé sas est dépassé
et doctor pourquoi j'ai fait ça alors
pourquoi ils le font au lieu de faire
directement le truc plus légers parce
que ça coûte moins cher pourquoi oui ça
coûte moins cher il faut bon après faut
avoir une expertise tout ça pour pour
faire des façades seront fatidiques
continue comme ça il n'y a pas de jeu
c'est parce qu'ils se disent eux en tout
cas parce qu'en france on fait bazas en
france il ya une règle d'or c'est la
préservation tissulaire serre on
préserve les tissus dentaires l'émail la
dentine au maximum oui donc voilà c'est
on essaye de conserver au maximum parce
que il faut pouvoir ré intervenir sur
ses dents là en fait c'est dans la
admettant qu'elle se conservait une
vente si un jour on doit réintervenir
sur ses dents on doit les tuer tiens là
c'est tellement proche d'une ère que le
jour on doit réintervenir là dessus on
tue la dent donc ça veut dire que là ils
ont ils sont gen les patients qui sont
là y en a qui ont 19 ans dans 15 ans way
we say des patients gêne dans 15 ans si
on doit refaire une intervention basse
et on tue toutes les danses et
il aura des vraies dents dévitalisées
mais avec des prothèses dessus mais là
l'étape d'après oui ça sera peut-être
l'extraction un danseur bon alors on va
parler
des conseils d'un pour avoir les cinq
conseils du docteur never pour les dents
et puis d'année voilà ce qu'on devait
donc là les facettes il faut faire des
facettes c'est quoi ces faire quoi alors
qu'il sait quand on a des donc vous nord
en fait faut respecter après on fait
toujours le plus conservateur et moi il
ya un dd des mecs qui passent sur tik
tok qui est très sympa d'ailleurs je les
rencontre et qui a été fait pour des
facettes mais j'ai vu c'est d'en avant
et en fait ils avaient besoin juste
d'orthodontie et d'un éclaircissement
des dents donc il aurait pu sauver ses
dents et juste faire des traitements
conservateurs donc en fait on peut on
peut faire des facettes ci a besoin si
l'indication est posé on peut faire des
facettes mais des facettes batteur de
principes justes aujourd'hui aux
etats-unis c'est que les gens veulent
pas se taper 1 1 d'orthodontie c'est
pour ça qu'ils font des passages ouimet
président comme on a montré avec une
très fine pellicule là pas de souci
alors vous avez donné les cinq conseils
si vous nous rejoignez 20h40 une et cinq
conseils pour avoir des dons au top ce
que c'est important le premier conseil
savoir une hygiène bucco-dentaire
irréprochable oui en fait
c'est hyperimportant un beau sourire
c'est avant tout un sourire qui en bonne
santé c'était hyper hyper important un
sourire naturel 1 / et en bonne santé
c'est hyper important juste juste cyril
là on parle des conseils pour avoir une
bonne haleine pu
avant est ce que on peut on peut voir
comment vérifier si on a une bonne
haleine ouvrir sur ta raison badigeon en
hiver je prenais le test je vais
demander à 2,3 personnes ici de ne pas
le faire pour patrick
sayer pour savoir si on a une bonne ou
une mauvaise haleine en fait on va
tester notre haine comme s'ils ont testé
un parfum au caire est ainsi donc comme
ils font dans les parfumeries alors bien
sûr le poignet tu dois te lécher les
babines exactement lécher le poignet
l'intérieur ici du poignet tu l'as et
chez les chefs religieux attendant tu
l'as si cher tu la
vois tu l aimes ça dans le public aussi
prompts à faire ça l'a fait nanjing dans
le public
et même à la télé et même les les
téléspectateurs peuvent le faire aussi
si vous voulez chez avait le poignet
vous laissez sécher vous le sentez voilà
exactement c'est bien perdre j'en vois
beaucoup qui ne font pas assez
vous laissez sécher et après
alors
quoi
lubasa cette excuse
c'est bien
je vais madame
engagée sachant jouer pour rire un peu
santé importants en anglais c'est le
parfum
du coup ça veut dire quoi voilà et ben
ça veut dire que on va on va parler des
cinq conseils premier au conseil c'est
l'hygiène bucco dentaire est reprochable
parce que dans 85% des cas mauvaise
haleine on appelle ça la littoz ça vient
de la bouche ça vient pas des
[Rires]
poumons ça peut bien d'accord peut venir
des sinus et ça venir de plein d'autres
trucs mais dans 85 % c'est la bouche
d'accord voilà donc première
premièrement il ne manque qu'une bucco
dentaire et peu fiable si on souffre d
little il faut se brosser aussi la
langue avec ingrate lang a déjà vu ça
voilà donc il faut le faire avec la
brosse à dents
avec ce cas derrière la tête de la
brosse et l'espèce des petites surfaces
siliconée faut pas le faire avec la
brosse à dents parce que les poils de la
brosse à dents peuvent faire des micro
irritation petit des mutations sur la
langue la langue râpeuse mais c'est
surtout que les bactéries responsables
est mauvaise et ne peuvent se loger dans
ces petites irritations et ça peut être
pire mais non rappeuse mathieu c'est pas
bon
pour mykonos et mal vu ça ça peut-être
trois jours de vacances
ça c'est sûr c'est qu'on prend deux
minutes et demie c'est important et
c'est important de respecter ça parce
que tout va beaucoup me disent mais
c'est bon je me brosse deux fois par
jour mais qui brosse 45 secondes et
c'est la durée très importante ces deux
minutes deux fois par jour et on change
sa brosse à dents aussi tous les deux
mois c'est important aussi pareil pour
que ce soit efficace alors il faudra
faire un bain de bouche à bouche on peut
aussi exactement aussi il faut leur
ajouter n'empêche que j'ai urgence et
wiba on peut faire un bain de bouche
d'ailleurs il y en a des spéciaux contre
l'élite aux accords bains de bouche le
soir on peut y a pas de souci moi je
préfère sans alcool mais voilà faut bien
s'hydrater aussi exactement bien
s'hydrater c'est très important à aller
voir son dentiste au moins une fois par
an parce que on a beau avoir une bonne
hygiène s'il ya des caries des mâts d
atteindre parodontale sur des maladies
des gencives tout ça
c'est
ça peut ça peut ça peut déclencher une
mauvaise haleine bien s'hydrater et
faire attention à ce qu'on mange il ya
toujours des aliments dans les cônes et
l'ail
voilà certaines épices l'alcool tout ça
puisse en mauve et le paprika ouais
exactement bah voilà tout ça va faire
attention favoriser la seule h animation
ça c'est avec les chewing gum avec des
pastilles parce que quand il ya prés
salive d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que le
matin vous savez que le matin en elle
même une mauvaise haleine alors pas pour
moi le matin mais pour beaucoup de gens
le matin ses deux cent mille euros par
mois
soto pyrolyse
[Applaudissements]
monaco n'a donc pourquoi pourquoi parce
que la nuit il n'y a pas de salies on a
moins de savim est du coup assez pour ça
que c'est important de favoriser la
situation avec tout ça les pastilles
penser à moi j'ai quelqu'un en fait
pendant la nuit
une personne voilà qui vient qui met un
petit peu mou le goût je le sent même
pas pendant les genoux voilà et c'est
reparti c'est pour ça qu'à que pendant
le voilà et aussi parce que pourquoi
pendant le ramadan pendant qu'ils
pourront plus de la gueule c'est ça
c'est parce que on ya déjà le jeune ça
fait un peu ça et est aussi pareil on a
la bouche sèche on peut pas boire on a
la bouche sèche et ça
les bactéries responsables de la
mauvaise haleine se développe beaucoup
plus facilement dans la voix la connaît
la bouche sèche donc quand c'est pas
hydratée ouais mais après je développe
tout ça dans mon livre c'est un peu la
cdc ouvriers comme des beurs voilà pour
avoir un sourire éclatant où il avait
lui cyrille joly doit les invités et
d'ailleurs ça va je veux dire c'est ce
que j'ai après avoir lu ce livre un
monsieur rires non j'aurais jamais j'ai
jamais peur de sourire avant j'avais
peur de se ré depuis que j'ai lu le
livre je n'ai plus peur de s'ouvrir
[Applaudissements]